the Joe Rogan experience I had to make
that decision this year I found out I'm
not a psychopath it was very reassuring
yeah you told me about that story you
know yeah that was I don't know to be
honest I'll tell the story but uh before
I forget the thought it was everything
else associated with what happened after
that I found more impactful and yeah and
the stuff that lasted there stays with
you
it wasn't what actually happened it was
seeing the aftermath and like the system
and how it all yeah
pans out yeah we had a we had two home
invasions within 36 hours I guess
the first time the guy came in in the
middle night about 2:30 3:00 a.m. and
our backdoor had the sensor on made a
very signature noise and if you live in
your house you know the noises in your
house and it's for whatever reason it
just woke me up from a dead sleep and I
knew what I heard and there's only thing
that would make that noise so I kind of
snaked my way out the hall and down to
the top of the stairs and when I hit the
top of the stairs I heard the dog growl
and the door closed back so I knew that
was somebody leaving we have a huge
[ __ ] dog um basically useless but he
did growl and he made a very primitive
noise I was proud of him and the guy
didn't come in because of that and I
still went downstairs kind of swept the
ground floor then he was gone I didn't
want to freak my wife out so I waited to
the morning at teller and then we called
police of course one of the neighbors
got in like a ring cam in the back alley
the guy leaving and going down the
street so I had a very clear view of him
and for whatever reason my wife and the
kids they had to go on down to where we
actually live I was working that week in
Nashville probably mixing a record or
something so I just stayed behind and as
a result of me being home alone that day
I was cleaning and working on a firearm
I'd recently purchased and assembled and
went to bed that night locks everything
up and you know because they weren't
home I put the gun on the floor
on a padded case next to the bed so I'm
letting the next morning it's like 7:15
a.m. like sun-shining neighbor is going
to work and I hear the back door open
again and I was like this can't you know
what the [ __ ] that the maid who would be
here that early and I guess out of
paranoia or whatever reason I grabbed
that gun and just went to the top of the
stairs to look I still think it's the
maid and when I hit the top of stairs
and looked down the staircase same guy
same clothes just standing in my living
room rolling the cord up on my
headphones and I was saying all right I
was almost impressed one that he came
back was just like a complete was
happening at this time you know so I
started down the stairs on him very
quietly and I got about halfway down by
the time he like turned and saw me and I
was looking through his at his [ __ ]
head through a red dot like a video game
I'll never forget that image of this guy
like probably thinking he's about to die
and the back door was thankfully still
open the only thing I said to him was
what are we doing here man and I hit him
with a strobe which kind of like
probably to his brain was he thought was
the gun going off because he kind of
like seizure and then I salt the
adrenaline spike and he turned went out
the back door and jumped clean off my
[ __ ] porch like never hit a single
step and ran at the back gate he had
latched it and I saw this on the video
later when he came in he shut the back
gate back so he hit that back gate on a
dead rant on a dead run I just like blew
it the hell latches and wood splinters
flying it like took off down the alley
and I was I'm still I was standing on my
porch with the [ __ ] you know yeah
looking like a jackass like of a
neighbor's literally walking out the
house going to work and [ __ ] I'm just
like okay that happened and then so then
the next thing there's like eight police
officers in my living room all they
wanted to see was my gun and every
single one of them asked me why I didn't
shoot the guy and which was I found very
interesting as a well I mean and I
thought about it
finally you would
down going down the stairs you would not
believe how much [ __ ] can go through
your head in like four seconds like I
had this whole conversation with myself
as to like wife and kids aren't here you
know this guy doesn't even know I'm here
yet I'm holding a [ __ ] assault rifle
and he's not a threat to me but if I put
one through his dome which I have every
legal right to do right now there's
gonna be News vans on my lawn this is
gonna be on your [ __ ] Wikipedia page
today you know really all of that I'm
just like this guy's not a threat
yeah and thankfully he chose to go out
the door with all those it was just so
weird they were like why didn't you
shoot him I was like and I said that and
they just kind of looked at me and I was
like by that you know literally by the
time we engaged man two seconds later
he's running out the door so where am I
shoot him in the back and then you put
me in prison and they were like ah [ __ ]
man twice in a week you'd been fine we
figured something out figured something
out and who wants to take that chance
oh yeah yeah with a life in prison or
not yeah roll the dice I mean if he did
turn to ran at me we'd probably be
having a different conversation yes but
he didn't right now or if you reached
forgot anything
yeah which he didn't yeah was he a
junkie
no no he's like 25 honestly I saw his
whole [ __ ] life on his face you know
I mean it just like uh probably hard
times just a mass punk kid probably like
I was I didn't do any [ __ ] like that
when I was his age but no his toxicology
came back clean he had like one prior
for possession
it was hard times desperate yeah so I
got subpoenaed because I was the only
one that actually met him and I go to
the court case and you know it was very
interesting and telling experience for
me because I've never really been to
anything like that and he was one of
maybe eight or nine other people on the
docket that they all assigned the same
public defender who literally shows up
15 minutes before they start the day to
familiarize himself with every single
case and you just saw this factory like
these young underprivileged black males
just getting pumped into the system the
DEA came over she was just like thanks
for being here yada yada and you know
there was unluckily
for him he broke in like 13 other houses
and they had him on tape and a lot of
things so we had 13 or 14 aggravated
burglary charges which is pretty [ __ ]
heavy
you know it's every one of those Class B
so he was looking at 12 to 15 I think he
sang like a bird pleaded down got six
and then if he does a successful
rehabilitation program and prison he
could be out in two and it's usually
yadda-yadda and I just realized like wow
they're just just throwing this kid's
life away because he you know granted he
came into some people's houses and he
probably and he almost got [ __ ]
killed and they caught him the next
night like three streets over in the act
doing the same thing but he had no
priors he wasn't on drugs it was just
like no Direction probably no discipline
no guidance no heroes and I struggled
with that I was like man there's got to
be like what if I gave him a job it
depends entirely on who he is right
which I never got the chance to sit down
and find that bond that I've never got
to talk to him faced it might turn out
he was just some punk [ __ ] kid I'd be
like good luck man you know it might
turn out awesome it might turn out
terrible it's depending upon the person
but there's so many people in this
country that are set up to fail
[Applause]